madame la Première ministre le premier
quinquennat du président Macron a été
marqué par de nombreux renoncements dans
le domaine de notre souveraineté
industrielle Alstom Alcatel technique
Dassault est aujourd'hui un de nos
derniers champions industriel tricolore
exerçant en leadership mondial dans son
domaine l'aviation de combat or depuis
plusieurs années le projet d'avion de
combat européen du futur le Scaff fait
l'objet d'un bras de fer entre Français
et Allemand sur la maîtrise d'oeuvre du
projet avec en toile de fond la question
de la maîtrise du savoir-faire
industriel ce projet a été plusieurs
fois reporté notamment parce que le
gouvernement allemand faisait du partage
de la technologie de Dassault un
préalable à toute discussion or dans un
contexte franco-allemand largement
dégradé je pense au désaccord sur la
gestion de la crise énergétique à
l'annulation du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand ou à de nombreux projets
de coopération militaire déjà abandonnés
Ant du futur ou le drone européen le
gouvernement allemand a communiqué de
manière unilatérale sur la conclusion
d'un accord accord que vous avez
vous-même confirmé madame la Première
ministre lors de votre déplacement
vendredi dernier à Berlin
or quelques heures après l'entreprise
Dassault a rappelé que rien n'était
signé madame ma première ministre où en
est-on donc sur ce dossier un accord
a-t-il été trouvé pouvez-vous garantir
solennellement alors présentation
nationale que c'est bien d'assaut qui
sera maître d'oeuvre de l'avion de du
système de combat pouvez-vous assurer
que les droits de propriété
intellectuelle sur les brevets actifs
stratégiques de la Défense nationale ne
seront pas cédés et pouvez-vous nous
certifier que d'assuer la France
garderont toute leur liberté d'action
pour l'exportation de ces avions sans
ces garanties ce serait une énième
soumission française face à l'Allemagne
pour sauver la Grande Illusion d'un
couple franco allemand sur le dos de
Dassault et ce serait inacceptable